[Music]
not only are ariana grande and kelly
clarkson competing against each other on
the voice everyone was such a big fan of
hers now the pair and their fellow
coaches john legend and blake shelton
are facing off in the premiere episode
of jimmy fallon's new nbc game show
that's my jam it's a showdown
which means going against
[Applause]
in a teaser from the episode jimmy tasks
ari and kelly with singing a medley of
classic hits during the show's mixtape
medley showdown segment i think it was a
great move with a spin of the show's big
wheel the two are assigned to the genre
pop divas and well audiences get a real
musical treat
yeah that's the god is a woman singer
belting out britney spears and kelly
covering shania twain it was like so
crazy but it didn't stop there ari did
her best version of cher's belief
[Music]
[Music]
and kelly totally crushed elena's more
sets you ought to know
[Applause]
and if you thought that was impressive
just listen to the powerhouse singers
covering whitney houston and tony
braxton respectively
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
say you
well the guys certainly seem to enjoy it
it's literally shocking but it wouldn't
be a pop diva sing-off without a little
celine dion i was born
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
fans will just have to watch the new nbc
series when it airs november 29th to see
who wins but there's no denying ari
takes the cake for best celine
impression oh thank you not only has she
wowed fans with her impression on the
voice
hello that's my run
oh my god i love your impression she
also busted it out back in 2015 during a
stop by the tonight show singing the
weekend's hit track can't feel my face
in celine's iconic voice
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
as for the competition between kelly and
ari well back in may before season 21 of
the voice started filming eti caught up
with a stronger singer who said she
couldn't wait to have ari's good energy
on the show i'm a huge fan of her voice
i love her voice i've only run into her
a couple times and she's so sweet like
every time we run into each other so i'm
just a fan she syncs so beautifully and
is
just killing it still in the charts like
she's just an amazing coach like to have
on the show so i think it's going to be
really cool and fun and i like female
energy